Salut, aujourd'hui,
on va parler du toucher, des caresses,
des câlins, de toutes ces petites choses
qui font du bien, mais qu'on est contraint
de laisser de côté en raison du contexte actuel.
Et, pour notre génération,
c'est la première fois qu'on
est privé de contacts physiques.
Alors pourquoi le toucher est si essentiel
à notre développement dès la naissance?
Et surtout, quels sont
les quatre bienfaits
un peu méconnus, mais très stylés du contact physique ?
Et l'impact qu'a l'absence
de contacts physiques,
quand on se rencontre, sur notre santé ?
Même sur notre cerveau,
il y a des impacts.
Il faut qu'on en parle, vous et moi.
Loïc générique.
Oui, je vous en reparlerai tout à l'heure,
mais la vidéo d'aujourd'hui est
sponsorisée par le VPN des VPNs , NordVPN.
Est-ce que vous savez ce que c'est un VPN?
Oui, vous le savez déjà et je vais quand
même vous expliquer à la fin de la vidéo.
Mais si vous êtes impatients,
et vous vous dites oui, mais moi,
je ne connais pas NordVPN.
Déjà, bienvenue sur Internet.
Vous étiez où depuis toutes ces années ?
Mais sachez quand même qu'avec le lien
en description et mon code Fabien Olicard,
vous avez une grosse réduction
sur l'abonnement de deux ans.
Le toucher, sujet sensible pour les blagues
quand tu avances avec un doigt comme ça.
C'est le premier sens qui se
développe dans l'utérus et c'est un peu
le premier langage qu'on apprend.
Il y a de nombreuses études qui démontrent
l'importance de pratiquer le peau
à peau dès la naissance du bébé.
C'est à dire le tenir tout nu contre soi.
Ce contact lui procure un sentiment
de sécurité et de bien-être,
mais cela régule également son rythme
cardiaque et cela lui permet une meilleure
respiration, une meilleure gestion de son
taux de glycémie, de sa température.
Et je vous avoue qu'avant de faire cette
vidéo, je savais que le toucher
avait des bienfaits.
Mais je ne m'attendais pas
à autant de bénéfices.
C'est assez impressionnant, c'est très stylé.
Vous allez voir.
Je vais déjà vous lister les quatre
principaux bienfaits.
Le troisième va vous surprendre.
Première surprise, cela va vous surprendre aussi.
Cela fait des années
que vous me demandez mes
sources en description.
Je trouve que c'est
relou et que ça n'incite pas,
au contraire,
à aller chercher l'information soi-même
quand on veut aller plus loin.
Mais je vais vous mettre de la source
en description grâce à Laura,
qui a co-écrit cette vidéo avec moi
et qui fait le travail de sourcing
dans un fichier pour pas qu'on
oublie d'où viennent les sources.
Je vais vous faire un copier coller de ça. C'est pour moi.
Le toucher,
ça déclenche de l'endorphine,
la fameuse substance chimique qui a
des effets antalgiques et qui sont
susceptibles d'atténuer la douleur.
Mais c'est pas tout.
Selon des chercheurs de l'Université
du Colorado et de l'Université d'Haïfa,
le contact de la peau permet aussi
de synchroniser les ondes cérébrales
de deux personnes. Et si une des personnes
souffre physiquement et qu'une autre
personne offre un contact physique,
les ondes cérébrales de la personne
souffrante vont se calquer ni plus ni
moins sur la personne non souffrante.
En bref, une activité cérébrale ralentie
qui engendre une relaxation de son corps.
Pour Pavel Goldstein,
le co-auteur de cette étude,
cela illustre la puissance
et l'importance du contact humain.
Dans le même registre,
une autre expérience passionnante a été
menée par ces mêmes chercheurs sur 22
couples de 23 à 32 ans. Dans chaque couple,
la femme recevait
une stimulation douloureuse.
C'était des couples hétérosexuels.
De son côté, son partenaire agissait
de trois manières différentes.
Soit il lui tenait la main,
soit il était assis à côté d'elle,
mais sans la toucher, soit il était
dans une pièce complètement séparée.
Parallèlement, les réactions cérébrales
étaient enregistrées via
un encéphalogramme parce que sinon,
il n'y aurait pas de données.
Le résultat, c'est quoi?
Et bien, dans le premier cas,
celui où le couple se tenait la main,
les fréquences cardiaques,
la respiration et les ondes
cérébrales étaient synchronisées.
La femme adaptait donc inconsciemment,
par son corps,
son comportement en fonction de ce
que son partenaire ressentait.
Et dans les deux autres cas où ils ne se
touchaient pas, il n'y avait
aucune synchronisation.
Même quand il était dans la pièce.
Selon les chercheurs,
la personne souffrante a l'impression
d'être un peu entendue,
un peu comprise et accompagnée
grâce à ce contact physique.
C'est pour cela que les mécanismes
de récompense s'activent dans le cerveau
et que cela agit comme un antidouleur.
Autre bienfait, le contact physique
nous aiderait à estomper nos peurs.
Une autre expérience, toujours menée
sur des couples,
a montré que lorsque le couple se tenait
la main, ils éprouvaient moins d'angoisse
à l'annonce d'une décharge
électrique imminente.
Vraiment?
On fait des études encore avec
de l'électricité en décharge.
Dans le cerveau,
les zones impliquées dans les réactions
de peur se sont montrées moins actives.
Il s'avère que même la main d'un étranger
pouvait faire office de contact.
Ça pouvait rassurer. Tout ça grâce à
l'hormone du lien, la fameuse ocytocine,
qui procure un sentiment de confiance.
Ce lien physique réduit considérablement
le stress en diminuant aussi
le niveau de cortisol.
Et ça, par contre, quand on a du cortisol
dans le sang, c'est pas bon.
C'est ça, le stress.
Une autre expérience sympa dont j'aurais
bien aimé être le cobaye,
tient pour une fois,
a été menée sur les vertus du massage
et son impact sur notre organisme.
C'est autre chose
que des décharges physiques.
Et qu'est ce qu'on
constate dans ce cas-là?
Ecoutez, je vais vous le dire. Ça fait
longtemps qu'il n'était pas venu celui-là.
On constate un ralentissement
des ondes cérébrales,
un état de détente similaire
à une personne profondément endormie.
Et dans ce cas,
le cerveau réagit au massage en réduisant
son activité, en libérant des hormones
et des neurotransmetteurs qui circulent
dans le sang jusqu'à atteindre
les autres parties du corps.
D'un coup, les muscles, ils se disent,
il faut se détendre.
La fréquence cardiaque, elle diminue.
La respiration ralentit.
En bref, tout contact physique va
engendrer une réaction biologique.
Est ce que vous saviez que le contact
physique nous rend plus sûr de nous?
C'est intéressant, surtout
par rapport à la distanciation qu'il y a en ce moment.
Il y a plusieurs études
qui montrent que des élèves qui reçoivent
un léger contact physique sur le bras ont
près de deux fois plus de chances de se
porter volontaires en classe
que ceux qui n'en reçoivent pas.
C'est quand même pas rien.
Les recherches du professeur
de psychologie sociale Nicolas Guéguen
à l'Université de Bretagne-Sud montrent
également que certains élèves peuvent
améliorer littéralement
leurs résultats scolaires grâce à ça.
Des élèves avec de mauvaises
notes ont eu de meilleurs résultats suite
à un entretien où le professeur apportait
du soutien par un geste physique
sur le bras ou sur l'épaule,
plutôt qu'un entretien sans contact.
Plus insoupçonné encore, le toucher
active certaines connexions neuronales
et permet de réguler la digestion.
Ça nous aide aussi à bien dormir et même
à booster notre système immunitaire.
Étant donné que le contact physique,
ça produit une diminution du taux de cortisole
l'hormone du stress,
je vous le disais tout à l'heure, cela stimule, dans le même temps, la production de lymphocytes,
qui lui, une fois dans le sang,
booste le système immunitaire.
Et quand on manque de contacts physiques,
ça donne quoi?
C'est intéressant, dans un premier temps,
qu'est ce que ça donne chez des enfants
privés de contacts dès le plus jeune âge?
Réponse : c'est catastrophique.
Pour les humains,
c'est une catastrophe.
Dans les années 1990,
de nombreux enfants dans des orphelinats
roumains ont subi des retards
de développement.
Les enfants en question étaient très
négligés dans ces centres
et ne recevaient quasiment
jamais de contacts physiques.
La majorité de ces enfants souffraient
d'un retard de développement, tant
au niveau physique qu'au niveau mental.
Pire, d'après des études faites par IRM,
les enfants qui ont grandi dans ces
orphelinats avaient un cerveau
physiquement plus petit que leurs
homologues qui étaient en bonne santé.
Ils étaient aussi plus enclins à générer
des comportements agressifs, des troubles
divers d'ailleurs, du comportement.
Aujourd'hui, avec cette distanciation
physique imposée,
quelles sont les conséquences que nous,
on a depuis que votre pote ne vous tape plus
sur l'épaule ou que votre
chère grand mère ne vous fait plus :
Alors comment il va lui?
Alors, viens me voir Loïc.
Je voulais illustrer un truc.
Tu arrives à ce moment là, c'est parfait.
Tu sais, quand ta grand-mère,
par exemple, elle te faisait
alors, comment il va Loïc? Comment il
va? Il est sage.
Tu vois ça te manque.
Je faisais comme ça.
Je prenais sa main.
Alors Mamie.
Ca va, écoute,
ça va comme ça.
Elle courait comme moi ou pas?
C'est incroyable cette histoire.
Cette privation de toucher,
elle n'est pas sans conséquences.
Elle peut engendrer de lourdes
séquelles psychologiques.
Vous l'avez vu sur Loïc, par exemple,
sa réaction.
Lorsque vous manquez...
Prolongez en tout cas,
En tout cas, en anglais,
on utilise même un terme spécifique
pour parler de la privation de toucher.
Ça se dit comment c'est la faim,
la faim de la peau?
Comment tu traduirais ça, Loïc?
Non pas la fin,
la faim.
Skin hunger
La chercheuse Beate Ditzen, je ne
sais pas prononcer les noms, de l'Institut
psychologie médicale du CHU d'Heidelberg.
C'est une étude dès le premier confinement pour savoir
les effets de la distanciation
sociale sur nous.
Et ce n'est pas dur.
C'est pas facile à dire,
la distanciation sociale.
C'est 250 foyers allemands qui ont
participé à l'étude et, au préalable,
chaque personne de chaque foyer a dû
effectuer un petit test salivaire
et répondre à un questionnaire
à différentes dates.
Avec-vous des questions comme :
Avez-vous des douleurs?
Avez-vous eu des contacts corporels?
Quel est votre niveau
de stress et d'anxiété?
Exactement avec cette voix.
Les réponses ont ensuite été comparées
à des mesures hormonales via le test
salivaire, qui ont permis d'obtenir
des données biologiques qui ont pu être
comparées à des données subjectives.
C'est à dire les réponses aux questions.
Merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo.
Bonne fin de soirée, c'est pas fini.
Qu'est-ce qu'ils révèlent ces tests?
Ecoutez, je vais vous le redire.
Il y a peu de surprises.
Le taux de cortisole est moins
élevé chez les personnes qui ont
des contacts physiques agréables.
Par exemple, quand Loïc je lui faisait ça,
c'était agréable pour lui.
Par contre, quand il m'a fait ça,
ce n'était pas agréable pour moi.
Pour Kory Floyd,
le professeur de communication
à l'Université d'Arizona.
Je dis ça parce que tout le monde connait.
Il y a un vrai lien entre le manque
d'affection tactile, le stress,
la dépression, la solitude et l'anxiété.
Il ajoute : les personnes qui vivent
seules sont certainement plus sensibles.
A l'heure actuelle,
je pense qu'il est raisonnable d'affirmer
que presque tout le monde est plus
sensible que la normale au manque
de toucher et à d'autres formes
de comportement affectueux.
Selon Tiffany Field,
directrice de l'Institut de recherche
sur le toucher de l'Université de Miami
et titulaire au passage d'un petit doctorat
en psychologie du développement.
Elle dit : la privation de toucher est
un traumatisme fort pour les personnes
qui ont l'habitude d'être beaucoup
touchées et qui sont maintenant séparées.
Comme les nouvelles relations amoureuses
ou les personnes hospitalisées.
Dans une enquête qu'elle a menée auprès
de 260 adultes du 25 mars au 5 mai 2020,
son département a constaté que 43%
des personnes interrogées avaient fait
l'expérience de la solitude,
58% se sentaient isolées
et 42% se plaignaient de se
sentir privées de toucher.
Cela veut dire qu'il y
avait un vrai manque.
Question comme dirait Dwight,
Est-ce qu'il nous faudrait
un temps d'adaptation avant de pouvoir
enlacer nos proches à nouveau,
une fois la situation rétablie ?
Ou est-ce que ça va être automatique ?
Eh bien, la réponse est oui,
il en faudra un.
D'après de nombreux épidémiologistes et
experts interrogés par le New York Times,
comme on a pris cette habitude d'avoir
moins de contacts physiques spontanément
avec les personnes qui nous entourent,
une fois que la situation est redevenue
normale, on aura du mal à revenir à ces
gestes, de se toucher, de se faire des câlins,
des accolades, un peu pour un oui
ou pour un non. Selon ces mêmes experts.
Il faudrait plus d'un an, c'est quand même long,
pour se sentir à nouveau complètement
à l'aise pour serrer la main de quelqu'un
ou lui faire juste une accolade.
Et dans le premier temps,
le retour des contacts vont
ressembler presque à une intrusion
à l'intérieur de nous dont on
voudrait se protéger.
Et en parlant de se protéger,
il est grand temps de vous parler de NordVPN.
Vous l'avez pas vu venir, elle!
Vous connaissez déjà sans doute ce VPN
qui s'annonce aujourd'hui comme étant
le plus rapide du marché et le plus simple
d'utilisation avec connexion automatique
pour une protection sans aucune
intervention de votre part.
Mais du coup, ça sert à quoi?
NordVPN?
Bouge pas, je te le dis.
À surfer avec plus
de sécurité lorsque vous allez
sur des Wi-Fi publics, par exemple dans
un bar, dans une bibliothèque,
en voyage, ca va revenir,
mais aussi à contourner les géo-restrictions
pour justement regarder des programmes
étrangers ou des programmes français
quand vous êtes à l'étranger.
Et pourquoi pas aussi accéder à des jeux
vidéo, des contenus animés, sportifs
comme la Formule 1,
qui ne sont pas disponibles dans le pays
dans lequel vous vous trouvez.
C'est pratique et c'est utile.
Sur le téléphone, ça fonctionne très bien.
on peut chercher aussi
des choses nouvelles.
Par exemple, je suis en France,
je peux faire un petit saut en Suisse.
Pourquoi pas, c'est à côté.
Pendant que je suis en Suisse, je me dis
tiens, j'en profite pour aller en Italie.
Mais là, je suis petit joueur,
donc je vais aller dans un quartier
italien très peu connu,
le quartier de la Corée du Sud.
Par NordVPN ou dans la vraie vie?
Dans la vraie vie.
Alors là, on peut choisir en bas.
Je fais un petit saut aux Etats-Unis
parce que j'avais une course à faire.
Mais on peut chercher directement
comme ça dans la liste.
En fait, il n'y a pas grand chose à
expliquer tellement c'est simple en fait,
en réalité. Voilà.
Aller. Nouvelle-Zélande.
Si vous cherchez un VPN,
c'est sûrement NordVPN qu'il vous
faut. En tout cas, c'est le sponsor de
cette vidéo. Donc c'est important.
Passez par mon lien en description.
Utilisez le code Fabien Olicard
pour bénéficier d'un abonnement de
deux ans, plus un mois supplémentaire
gratuit avec une énorme réduction.
C'est pour ça que je fais
ces mots très forts.
En plus de ça, vous avez
un service client français dispo.
Ça, c'est cool en vrai 24/24,
7 jours sur 7 ainsi que la garantie
de remboursement de 30 jours.
Essayer NordVPN,
c'est sans risque et ça fait plaisir.
Merci NordVPN!
Je trouve ça fou d'ailleurs d'être
le premier à vous en parler.
En plus. Je crois.
Je regarde pas trop Internet.
Revenons-en à nos caresses.
Le souci, c'est que quand on manque
de quelque chose, notre corps
cherche à le compenser.
Certaines personnes vont davantage
manger, d'autres dormir en plus.
En bref, on cherche un substitut,
quel qu'il soit, pour avoir une sensation
de bien-être par un autre biais.
C'est comme quand vous avez faim.
Votre cerveau vous dit "Hey, j'ai faim"
et bam, vous passez à l'action.
Sauf que là, vous ne pouvez pas passer
à l'action et l'absence de contact,
c'est un peu plus compliqué de répondre
à la demande de votre cerveau
pour le faire. Donc, pour pallier
à ce manque de contact,
des ingénieurs sont en train de travailler
sur la création d'une peau artificielle,
une sorte de seconde peau qu'on pourrait
placer sur différentes parties du corps.
Ce n'est pas vraiment pour pallier
au manque de contact, cela à
d'autres utilisations.
C'est une peau qui serait
connectée à un ordinateur.
Et quand on toucherait l'écran,
il y aurait des capteurs électroniques
qui s'activeraient,
et qui provoqueraient des vibrations
ou des pressions.
C'est une peau qui est à l'état de test,
qui n'est pas encore capable de simuler,
par exemple, une caresse.
Mais elle peut enrichir la communication
même si elle ne remplacera
jamais un contact.
Par contre, pour les retours de jeux
vidéo, pour les feedback des sensations
de jeu, ça peut être intéressant,
mais dans pleins d'autres domaines.
En attendant,
vous pouvez pratiquer l'auto-câlin.
Genre, plutôt en vous massant le cuir chevelu,
en brossant votre corps dans un bain,
par exemple, en faisant des points
de pression sur certaines parties de votre
corps pour activer
les récepteurs de la peau.
C'est apparemment très efficace.
Le docteur Philippe
préconise par exemple de placer un sac
de riz ou de farine de quelques kilos
sur sa poitrine, allongé. Et selon elle,
cela aurait le même effet qu'une couverture
lestée qui pourrait remplacer un petit peu
comme ça, un contact...à essayer.
De toute manière, en vrai, se toucher soi-même, ça va jamais remplacer un contact avec les autres.
Mais en attendant, un auto
câlin vaut mieux que zéro.
Vous pouvez vous toucher du coup
en pensant à cette vidéo,
mais vraiment vous toucher.
On repart de cuir chevelu.
C'est dangereux
ce genre de vidéos, quand même.
Dites-moi d'ailleurs en commentaire
comment vous ressentez le manque
de contact physique en vrai?
Comment ça s'est passé cette année?
Est-ce que c'était facile?
Vous y avez pas pensé?
Est-ce que ça a été très douloureux ?
Je serais curieux qu'on échange à ce sujet.
J'espère en tout cas
que la vidéo vous a plu.
Merci beaucoup à NordVPN
d'avoir sponsorisé cette vidéo. Télécharger le
en passant par mon
lien dans la description.
Et vous profitez, je vous le dis,
d'un mois d'abonnement gratuit. Pourquoi on
remercie les sponsors comme NordVPN parce
que c'est grâce à eux qu'on peut financer
les gros projets que vous aimez bien,
les matières grises, les gros casses-têtes de fou,
les cabinets Curiouz.
Il faut comme ça des gens
qui jouent le jeu du sponsoring.
Et c'était leur cas.
Petite piqûre de rappel si vous avez raté
l'information, mon livre est sorti :
L'antiguide de la manipulation.
En gros, on est tous manipulateurs.
On peut l'être de manière bienveillante.
On peut déjouer les pièges
des gros manipulateurs.
Pourquoi la manipulation
ça marche sur le cerveau.
C'est sûrement le livre dont je suis  le plus fier.
N'hésitez pas à jeter un œil.
Vous avez un lien aussi dans la description.
Si vous ne me connaissez pas,
je m'appelle toujours Fabien Olicard.
Ça ne change pas.
C'est extrêmement pratique.
Là, je vous mets deux autres vidéos.
Une, c'est un défi, je devais répondre à six
énigmes de logique et une autre sur six
choses que vous devriez savoir,
si vous le ne le savez pas, c'est sur des inventions
qui ont été faites par hasard.
C'est très intéressant.
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner
et d'activer la cloche.
Tout ça, c'est gratuit.
Ça soutient mon travail.
Ça vous prévient des autres vidéos.
Vous connaissez, on vous le dit tout le temps.
Prenez soin de vous.
Faites vous des auto-câlins. À très bientôt.
Des petits calinoux. Des petits calinoux. Des petits calinoux.